Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
This will be my full Marvel
Secret Invasion Episode 6 Finale Video.
There are a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references and teasers
that set up upcoming Marvel Phase
five movies.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
I'll be doing episode videos for Ahsoka
when it starts in a couple of weeks.
And then Loki season two episodes later
this year.
There's still a bunch of big stuff
coming up,
including the Marvel's movie as well,
which this is meant to directly set up.
careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet
because we'll be talking about everything.
We'll just start at the beginning
and work our way through shot by shot,
talking about Easter eggs, WTF moments
and all the stuff that it sets up.
starting with the title home
which is a reference to the Skrulls
like the titular thing that Nick Fury
has been blamed for this entire series,
not finding the Skrulls at home.
in effect, the home winds up being earth,
as we suspected earlier.
Like the idea is that
the remaining Skrulls will live on Earth.
The big surprise
though is that there is no compromise.
I'd actually been expecting President
Ritson to go the complete other direction
and he actually declares all out
war on every Skrull, every man,
woman and child Skrull.
The only exception he makes are two aliens
who are born on earth
remember though he said aliens,
even though he was talking
mostly about the skrulls.
This includes asgardians
any alien that is born in outer space
and then comes to earth.
suddenly Valkyrie is waking up for a drunk
stupor, saying, Wait a minute, what?
Why are they trying to declare war
on new Asgard?
We're crazy strong.
There's no way they're going to defeat us.
somebody called Thor back to planet Earth.
So the whole idea here is
this is meant to set off off the Marvel
Phase five Dark Reign, where Thunderbolt
Ross eventually becomes President.
United States.
There's also a direct line that Nick Fury
has at the end of the episode,
where I think it completely foreshadows
how that winds up happening.
what happens at the end of the episode
with the war on the Skrulls
will also spill into daredevil born again
in set up how Kingpin winds up becoming
mayor in New York City during the events
of that series next year.
Although there is a strike right now,
there might be some delays.
I think that some of Daredevil born again
will premiere next year.
the actual opening scene is Nick
Fury calling their homes land line
for the first time.
He jokes like he's tried a bunch of times
this past 15 years,
that he's been away on missions
but never actually done it end,
even though he is Nick Fury,
he has iron clad plans
about how they're going to defeat gravity
and tricked the skrulls.
he still implies that he might not
make it back alive.
Like there's a small chance,
but a very small chance
then in the next scene,
they wind up paying off a bunch of people.
Is there is I saw a bunch of people
commenting about this.
So pat yourself on the back.
If you suspected that Emilia Clarke
was going to pretend
to be Nick Fury
when they went to New Sucralose secretly.
Emilia Clarke's G'iah pretends to be Nick
Fury coming to New Skrulls to engineer
that entire scenario
where she winds up taking him down,
taking revenge for the death
of her father, Talos, and her mother,
because gravity did technically kill
both of them in cold blood.
this is
meant to pay off that line of dialog
where she told Nick Fury she'd
put on a brave face that she literally
is going to pretend to be him
putting on his face in order to get close
enough to graphic to kill him.
Mostly because there's no way Nick Fury
would actually have a chance at beating
him in his Super Skrull form, including
getting the powers of all the Avengers
in a whole bunch of other villains,
including Thanos, of all people.
Like literally every person in the MCU
use powers is crazy.
and even if Nick Fury
did have super powers, the radiation
would slowly be killing him anyway.
But G'iah is both a Skrull largely
immune to the effects of the radiation,
and she's a super Skrull like grabbing.
We'll get way, way more power,
sort of be a much more even match.
they should also remind you that Nick
Fury's homo, like his whole thing in
the MCU, is just doing
really good resource management.
His resources just happen
to be super power people and super weapons
like The Avengers in the skrulls.
It's all about just being
a really good manager of people.
while this gets started?
Skrull Rhodey Squad is still trying
to get the President to attack
Russia to set off World War three.
All of his other advisors
have kind of a funny scene
like the fleet admirals, generals,
all telling him to chill
so they can get more information
before they completely nuke the planet
any of that.
They kind of buried the lead on this.
Early on, it seemed like the president
started to suspect
that something was up with Rhodey
because he had such a boner
for firing nuclear weapons on Russia.
then one guy in Nick Fury form starts
walking through the compound, coughing,
getting deeper into the power plant,
pulling out the meter,
that's all just for show, assuming
that there might be other skrulls there
watching her.
So she just wants to put on a good show
for them laying on extra thick coffee
a couple extra times.
Sonya Bosworth in the Real Nick Fury.
Try to work a smokescreen and trick Rhodey
into helping the president
so that they can get closer to him
and get rid of Skrull.
Brody that was the whole reason
why he told her the truth about Brody
in last week's episode,
so that she would know that he's Skrull.
when they start having the guy in Nick
Fury in graphic scenes, there are a couple
great speeches here, like great speeches
from Kingsley Ben-Adir.
In service of this, you kind of
have to bend over backwards a little bit.
Like there are a couple of leaps in logic
that they make,
like, okay,
you got to go with this on this.
The idea is the skrulls
should be able to detect each other.
So when she shows up
pretending to be Nick Fury, shouldn't
Gravett be able to detect that it's her?
they drop a whole bunch of Avengers
in comic book
references when he starts referencing
the Avengers coming to save him.
So thinking that it is Nick Fury,
the invisible cloak and shield
are references
to a couple of different things.
There's the organization Shield Itself,
which was dismantled in the MCU
after Winter Soldier.
There's also a reference
to Captain America Shield as well.
in at least in the comics,
Nick Fury has a special cloak
with unstable molecules
that turns him invisible, like it's
an invisibility cloak prevents him
from being detected by even the watcher.
That's how good it is.
They use the speech
for a little more backstory.
Exposition two graphic reveals
that the human face
he's been wearing this whole time.
Like Kingsley Ben-Adir
face is the face of the first human
that graphic ever killed
when he was going on missions for him,
when he had the skrulls operating as that
secret team within SHIELD, sort of his
answer to the Black Widow program.
the funny thing here, though,
he gets really mad and Nick Fury.
Yo, you don't remember that
this is the face of the person
that you asked me to kill.
The very first person is because
it's Emilia Clarke Sky character.
Of course
she would not remember that person.
under normal circumstances,
she would just take Nick Fury's memories
or copy his memories so that she would
learn more of these secrets.
But Nick Fury
secrets are kind of like his children,
like they're more precious to him
almost than The Avengers are.
there's no way that Nick Fury
was going to let her skin his mind
like,
No, no, no way. Too many secrets in there.
It's meant to be a very Cat's
in the Cradle kind of speech with gravity,
having it out with him in how he did
terrible things that drove him crazy,
all in the name of making Nick very proud.
Kind of like a son talking
about the approval of their father figure
early on, my theory
for why things were so personal between
gravity, Nick Fury is because he was kind
of like his surrogate father,
and they kind of implied
that early in the flashbacks.
But they never really
literally went there.
there are a lot of people
that even wondered
if he might be Nick Fury's biological son.
But obviously that's not true.
the vibe here is sort of like a child
realizing that their parents are fallible
people and utterly failed them in some way
when they become adults in this
case, is the failure to find the Skrulls
a permanent world to live on.
really solid speech here from Kingsley
Ben-Adir.
I feel like he's an amazing actor,
but most of the scenes
that they'd given him during
the series weren't up to his level.
Like he had a couple
good speeches during the series,
but only a couple win Emilia Clarke says
Nick Fury realized there were no suitable
other planets the Skrulls could live on.
It would have to be Earth.
That seems a little convenient.
Just engineer this scenario
The universe is meant to be massive.
Even if you're only talking
about habitable m-class planets
capable of sustaining life.
Scientists in real life
like this is a real thing based on data
believed there are about 10 billion
habitable planets out there.
10 billion. And Nick Fury couldn't
find one.
That is crazy They revealed
there's still a colony out there
in space somewhere
that's still loyal to the previous Skrull.
Emperor Talos
mentioned him a little while ago.
The Skrulls could have gone
to wherever that colony is.
the whole speech about it being easier
to save everyone's lives than it is
to change their minds
is the idea that everybody on Earth is
stuck in their ways and super xenophobic
against aliens that do not look like them,
which is the exception for the Asgardians
people generally love the Asgardians
like they love Thor, they love Valkyrie.
It seems like
it's a huge tourist destination.
but the whole idea is that as guardians
look pretty much like humans,
they could just walk around
normally undetected
and people wouldn't notice the difference.
Skrulls cannot do that.
I think part of the idea here is
because this is Emilia
Clarke pretending to be Nick
Fury, telling Gravity all these things.
a lot of this is meant to be G'iah's
take on everything
that's happened in the history
with Nick Fury.
it's not like Nick
Fury made her memorize a giant long speech
before she went in here.
Like, a lot of this is just coming
from her completely.
But part of the idea here is it's
meant to be kind of a long con.
This she's playing here
just trying to goad him into the situation
where he tries to give himself
all these powers and she gets powers to
That's what I think she meant
when she was talking about Nick Fury
wanting to escape
His responsibilities are being happy
that he was snapped during Avengers
Infinity War by Thanos
even though the real Nick Fury did
go to the Saber space station,
he was still working there, even though
he joked about it being a vacation.
he would never purposefully run away
from his responsibilities
or try to protect everyone.
plus the whole fact that he was giving
graphic all the Avengers, all these other
superpowered people's DNA should have been
a clue that this was meant to be a ruse.
Like, No, no, I want you to take this
and activate this device.
they make a bunch more Avengers references
and reveal that there's way more
super power of beings DNA inside there
besides just the original Avengers
and Captain Marvel.
Like it goes way beyond those characters.
the only show is part
of the read out on the screen,
but the ones they do show us are ghost
witch powers they use.
Later in the episode, she'll be back
during the Thunderbolts too.
So the character is coming back.
They have Thanos is DNA.
That would actually be enough by itself.
Like you don't need
all these other people's powers.
You just need Thanos powers
all of his black order, like Corvus,
Glaive, Cole, Obsidian, Ebony, more.
The outriders proxima, midnight.
They've also got the abominations DNA,
which is a little confusing
because the abomination wasn't
at the final battle in Avengers Endgame.
And that's where they got all this DNA.
there's Korg, the Guardians of the Galaxy,
Frost Beast, the Hulk, Black Panther.
Even though technically
he doesn't have powers, the same way
you think about superpowered beings,
the Heart-Shaped Earth
gives them super strength,
gives them some special superpowers.
they've got the Qataris, DNA,
all the major Asgardians like Thor,
Valkyrie, regular Asgardian DNA.
Just a little bit different from Thor's
DNA because he was born a Godzilla.
He has a special celestial DNA
Valkyries just meant to be
like a normal asgardian with extra weapons
that make her way more powerful,
like she's a highly trained asgardian.
they've also got winter soldier's DNA,
But his powers are meant to be
the exact same as Captain America.
So there's a bunch of duplicates here.
If we're talking about giving yourself
everybody's
powers,
like it doesn't seem very efficient.
the big idea here is that now
she has all these same powers
and she can perfectly mimic
pretty much any superhero
that was at the final battle
in Avengers Endgame
and a bunch of supervillains, too,
like Thanos.
Think about this crazy.
not just mimic their appearances,
but perfectly mimic
their powers like the Super Skrulls
from comic book Secret Invasion.
So this is like the small way
that they went.
Comic book, Secret Invasion,
this now basically makes her one
of the most powerful characters in the MCU
because technically, Scarlet Witch's
DNA would have been at the final battle
in Avengers Endgame,
meaning she got Scarlet Witch's DNA, too.
They just didn't show it on screen.
graphic starts to use Hulk gamma powers
to Hulk out trying to kill
who he still thinks is Nick Fury.
And they engineer this all
for a big reaction, John, where she stops
the punch and then goes Hulk in that one
hand in punches him out of the base.
this whole ending fight scene with them
just swapping around different powers
is basically like a larger version of that
ending cameo scene from Ryan Reynolds
Free Guy movie where he uses a bunch
of the Avengers powers at the same time.
Only that movie had a Chris Evans cameo,
funny how now we're going to see
Ryan Reynolds come back in Deadpool three
and do a whole bunch of crazy
Easter eggs and references
like it's going to get super meta
just because of all the X-Men,
the MCU stuff that are blending together.
when they're fighting, he starts
using abomination and Groot powers.
That's what the hardened
skin here is abomination, not the Hulk.
That's why his ears change shape
to look like the abomination.
This is new character design.
This started with the Shang Shi movie.
She starts healing herself
with the extremist powers,
then uses Drax Powers for some reason.
I'm not sure why Drax
Because she has access
to way more powerful powers
like the Hulk's powers when she teleports.
That's meant to be her using Ghost's
phasing ability.
He changes to Korg.
She also uses core abilities and frost
PS powers for frost based abilities
she switches to Captain Marvel's powers
in combination with cool obsidian powers
to make her body super durable.
the funny thing about that is that Captain
Marvel is already super durable,
so it'd be like Superman using a hammer.
Like Superman doesn't need a hammer.
It doesn't make him stronger
or more durable.
Graphic pretty much does the same thing.
Like they end the fight
mostly using Captain Marvel Base powers.
one of the weird moments,
though, is when she stops him midair
because of mantises abilities.
And here's the thing.
I think the justification for her knowing
how to use Mantis powers on the fly here,
like immediately, just that she gets them
is because Nick Fury
at some point has briefed her on
how everyone's powers work They engineered
this whole scenario, like Nick Fury
planned this out for this all to happen.
so. He probably showed her
the most epic Avengers level
YouTube tutorial on everyone's powers
that's probably why she's familiar
with how to use some of them.
you notice
when she posts up here
to watching him fall to the ground
after giving him a full blast of Captain
Marvel's powers,
her pose is meant to be a reference
to the same Captain Marvel post
she made at the end of that first movie.
speaking of Deadpool references,
she also makes another
epic superhero landing
before she finally takes him out.
she basically finally takes him out
with another full blast of Captain
Marvel's Powers.
in that's pretty much the end of gravity.
She winds up releasing
all the humans at the schools
that are captured at that particular base.
They wind up finding another base
with a ton more people.
Later in the episode, we see the real
Evatt Ross and the real Rhodey.
For those people wondering how
they were going to pay this off,
what happened to the real Rhodey?
And they confirm a long running theory
that it was after Captain America
Civil War, that they replaced him.
He's in the hospital gown that he was
in during Captain America Civil War.
That's when they swapped him out.
that means for a lot of Marvel
phase three in everything that's happened
up until now, he's been a Skrull.
That will be important for how they set up
Iron Man Armor War The whole idea is
that Skrull Rhodey used his access
to all this Iron Man technology
to do all these shady things all over
the globe in Rhodey has to deal
with the consequences of that
all that Iron Man tech falling
into all these shady people's hands.
one of those people winds up being Val
and the new president.
Thunderbolt Ross
The whole idea is that Val is responsible
for the resurrection of Ultron.
Accidentally let damage
control is kind of meant
to be a villain of that Armor War series.
They're already co-opting a lot of Iron
Man tech to begin with.
Like we saw that during Spider-Man.
No way home.
reportedly Justin Hammer's coming back
during that.
Like he'll probably get a pardon from Val
and Thunderbolt
Ross in order to work for them on Iron
Man Tech to build them more weapons.
and one of the consequences of
that will be the resurrection or the
reactivation of the Ultron Protocol,
which has been dormant this whole time.
sort of be kind of like a Rhodey versus
Ultron movie.
Ultimately Separately.
The real Nick Fury tries to save
the president with Sonya Fallsworth's help.
The reason why he didn't kill
all the secret servicemen is
because they're real people.
And if he had actually killed them,
he would be a fugitive
and have to go to jail
after this is all done.
Even if he did save the president.
and they finally answer the question
that a lot of people were asking
after last week's episode,
if you can prove
that someone has the Skrull,
get them to revert back to form
by just shooting part of their body.
Why didn't he do that before?
It's because they wanted to save it
for this moment here
where he shoots them in the head.
that also felt kind of convenient
because if he had done that
in last week's episode,
that would have solved a lot of problems.
the one of the bigger surprises
the episode is the president goes
a completely different direction
with all this like he declares open
war on the skrulls like he gives
this big presidential address to the U.S.
but pretty much everybody around the world
sees it thing that at least at first
they're mostly going after the skrulls
and they're going to kill
every single one of them,
inspiring a bunch of vigilantes,
which will make you think of Daredevil
Born Again and the Punisher character.
That's
basically his M.O. being a vigilante.
this is meant to set up the Marvel Phase
five dark, really
kind of a more sinister reign as villains
come to power and all these vigilantes
that they tease running around
good and bad vigilantes,
like the whole idea is
they're killing people left
and right in the streets and people
just running around shooting people
who they presume are skrulls
some of them are,
and some of them are not like that one
up, killing a bunch of innocent people.
that's what they show you.
The vigilantes in Great Britain
killing the real prime minister, thinking
that she was still a Skrull.
this will probably spill
into the events of Daredevil born again.
Expect them to address
that whole idea of street level vigilante
just going around, shooting
everybody in the street.
Kingpin also probably uses that
to become mayor in New York City, saying
that he'll get rid of the bad vigilantes
and get rid of the skrulls in Daredevil.
We'll just have to deal with that.
I've already done a whole bunch of videos
about dead of a born again, so I'll post
links down in the description.
But there were a couple of big news
releases recently about the villains
during that series.
They'll be 18 episodes,
so there's like a whole bunch of stuff
that's going on during that.
this is also where we get to
the big teaser for Captain America
four Brave New World and Thunderbolt
Ross becoming the next president
of the United States
after written here When Nick Fury calls
him tells me mucked everything
by declaring war on the Skrulls,
making the whole situation even worse.
He says that's a real one term
president kind of thing.
I think that explains how Thunderbolt
Ross becomes the next U.S.
president because he just winds up
winning the next election.
Think about it this way.
There's this whole war on skrulls
vigilantes everywhere
running around with guns, him
being this distinguished military man
that's basically thunderbolt
Ross specialty being a wartime president.
then they have a big teaser for Emilia
Clark's guy
character
and where she's headed in the future.
The movies.
Sonia Bosworth shows up to recruit her,
and it's meant to be
kind of like a parallel for Nick Fury
showing up to recruit Iron Man
for The Avengers in the Post-Credits scene
for the first Iron Man movie.
But this is meant to be a teaser
for Excalibur in the MCU.
they're basically like a British version
of The Avengers,
but they're doing a version that now,
it seems like in the MCU
some point I don't know which movie
that's going to happen in,
but for those of you
that have wanted to see Captain Britain,
some of the other major British characters
in the comics start showing up,
this is them basically saying, Oh, yeah,
we're probably going to do that.
this would be a really good excuse
to have a reunion between
Kit Harington's
Black Knight in Emilia Clarke in the MCU.
Like, don't I know you from somewhere?
Do you still also know nothing?
Part of the reason
why I think she's going to be doing
this stuff,
this Excalibur related stuff on Earth.
Leading the Skrulls
is because she's still kind of salty.
Nick Fury for everything that's happened
in the death of her parents.
part of the idea, too,
is that she's going to become the leader
of all the Skrulls on earth as well,
to kind of like the new Skrull empress.
When the series was first
announced a couple of years ago,
a lot of people wondered,
maybe she'll wind up being Verrocchio,
who is the straw empress
during secret invasion in the comics.
Remember though, the real Skrull emperor.
The former Skrull emperor Seems like
he's still alive out there with another
sect of Skrulls which could be bad news
for characters in the MCU in the future.
We'll see what they wind up doing
with those characters. Ben.
They have a big teaser
for the Marvel's movie.
When he starts talking to his wife
about the Kree being opened,
a peace talks with The Rose,
that's meant to be a reference
to the crisscross a war in the comics,
in their history, in the MCU.
They dealt with some of that during the
events of the first Captain Marvel movie.
The Priest Rule War is something that's
been going on for about a hundred years,
but it's been localized to
this part of the universe.
Is it spilled over into the Milky Way
galaxy like near Earth, just a little bit
during the events of that movie,
the trailer made it seem like this
is meant to be a ruse by the Kree
who are trying to rebuild
their power base in the movie
by stealing the resources from other
planets using the other bank like Ms..
Marvel's other bangle
that Dardennes winds up getting.
that does not seem like a race of people
who wants to make peace
with their ancient enemies
When he starts talking about the peace
summit and his wife says
that she has to eventually
come back to planet Earth,
that probably means that they'll address
that during the movie,
like it will have already happened
when the events of the Marvel's
movie picks up
and she'll have come back to Earth.
And she's
probably not going to be in that movie.
probably one of the other
biggest surprises of the finale here
is that there's no post-credits scene
and no big cameo scene.
I would have expected at least a cameo
from someone in the Marvel's movie
like Monica Rambeau
or Captain Marvel Right now.
And this is taking place.
Monica Rambeau has already started working
for him on that cyber space station.
You see that during the Marvel's trailer.
I've already done
a much bigger video
for the Marvel's trailer,
so I'll post a link to that down to the
description below and at the end of this.
But this is a to set up
Marvel Phase five Dark Rain era.
Just in general, some of the movies,
some of the Disney
Plus series will address that.
Not everything is going to crossover
Some of it's more connected to the Loki
Kang Multiverse War plot
and what's happening with Avengers five.
Kang Dynasty.
Like the other stuff like all
this is meant to be Earth based stuff
for the most part, with a few exceptions,
like the Marvel's movie.
as far as they said,
they don't have any plans to do
Secret Invasion season two,
but if you did spot any other Easter eggs
or references in the episode
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
there were couple great moments
that they had during the series,
but just in general, I would have liked
to see a more Avengers level version
that is like a more comic book
accurate version
of Secret Invasion
with a bunch more characters.
The next big thing will be the Asoka
episodes that will start in August.
Of course, I'll be doing videos
for all the episodes.
Then after that will be Loki season
two episodes later this year. So
be sure to enable alerts from my channel
so you don't miss any of that.
There'll be more trailers
for so pretty soon too.
And Loki season two as well.
click here for all my Comic-Con trailer
from this past weekend and click here
for that brand new Marvel's trailer.
Thank you so for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!